packers have a standard going to the
playoffs every single year except the
last two they've got plenty of work to
do to turn things around and chris these
are not
ted thompson's green bay packers
major money spent in free agency to load
up the team primarily on the defensive
side of the ball there's a much
different vibe in green bay a much
greater sense of urgency a higher degree
of accountability and a greater
willingness than we've ever seen in the
free agency era to go out and get
multiple guys usually it was one guy
every seven or eight years now they're
loading up the can and they're trying to
make the team better quickly yeah it's
refreshing and i think green bay would
be one of those teams on a short list
where i'd go you could argue they won
the offseason as far as some of the
moves they made
on the player front you know hey rashaan
gary in the first round darnell savage
also in the first round two awesome
talents to contribute to that defense
young guys but then you talked about it
free agencies zadaria smith preston
smith adrian amos on the defensive side
of the ball you know hey it's not going
to be all about aaron rodgers having to
just outscore everybody on a weekly
basis that's going to be nice the
biggest question i think that we
probably all have is the guy that's on
the screen right here if you're watching
tv we got a head coach who was a
one-year offensive play caller and was
the offensive coordinator of the 25th
ranked offense in football and now he's
the head coach and coaching aaron
rodgers and that's really what i am
looking forward to seeing what kind of
offense is he going to build up there in
green bay and how is it going to look
with aaron rodgers at the helm
and can he get through to not just aaron
rodgers but the rest of the team and i
think rogers realizes how he reacts to
matt leflore and interacts with matt
lafleur is going to go a long way toward
letting the rest of the locker room know
what they should or shouldn't do it's
not going to be an easy task for lafleur
it was a surprise hire by the green bay
packers but they're doing what they can
to make a more creative offense chris
that's been your big criticism the mike
mccarthy offense was too predictable it
was too stale and and it put too much on
aaron rodgers to go out there and make
things happen sometimes it has to be
more than just a quarterback with
incredible physical abilities making
things happen someone explained to me
last year part of that give and take
between coach and franchise quarterback
is sometimes the quarterback makes the
throw that makes the coach look good and
sometimes the coach comes up with a play
that gets the quarterback the easy
touchdown that makes the quarterback
look good and that's where the healthy
tension is hey i got you one there well
hey i got you one there and it goes back
and forth that's exactly right yeah i
mean even for aaron rodgers it can't be
every play drop back and please make
magic with your great you know athletic
physical ability you know even the great
tom brady hey of course they have that
relationship up in new england oh here
hey tom here's some plays to open you
know some easy completions get you going
oh hey way to go tom nobody was open on
that play call way to throw a laser in
there on a 25-yard comeback and that's
where you start to get growth as an
offense exactly right so you know big
questions there and still with green bay
in general you know offensive line was a
little bit of an issue last year lack of
a running game here the last few years
it puts more pressure on aaron rodgers
that's one where area i look at matt
lefleur nathaniel hackett is being the
offensive coordinator i think they can
improve and bring a much improved run
game scheme to the green bay packers
that's much needed so i look at that and
go yay that could be great for aaron
rodgers because of course we know his
ability to come off a play action and
make big throws is pretty special the
other thing mike i'll throw out there to
you too you know not a lot of household
names at the wide receiver position for
green bay you know who is going to be
that next guy other than devonte adams
that steps up with the wide receiver
position i think is the other thing to
look at for green bay going into the
season yeah because randall cobb is gone
jordy nelson is long gone and and there
was that criticism that aaron rodgers
had of the young receivers during
training camp last year they were doing
a session where the it was just kind of
all over the place and he called them
out and uh you've seen some growth
you've seen some development but that's
what's going to be a key requirement for
this offense to get to where it needs to
be the defense though yeah second year
with mike patton matt lafleur keeps mike
patton around pettin had done a great
job as a defensive coordinator in the
rex ryan system you get more players in
there that presumably fit what what mike
patton wants to do a little bit better
money spent draft picks invested you
know that the defense could be the big
surprise here and the better that
defense is again that takes heat off of
aaron rodgers in the offense too uh a
hundred percent that's the thing i think
i looked out of the off-season for the
first to your point right there yes you
know it's the first time i feel like
they're going to be able to depend on
the defense once again since maybe you
know 2011 12 to where okay you know we
might only have to go out there and
score 20 points to win this football
game it doesn't have to be rogers making
three four amazing throws to give us 30
points you know late in the fourth
quarter whatever it may be i really like
mike pettin as a defensive coordinator i
think the talent on this green bay
defense is real middle linebacker maybe
is the only area i look at to go okay
that doesn't jump out to me but when you
talk about the big guys up front kenny
clark mike daniels now with rashaan gary
i like that we talked about the smith
guys on the edge of the defense jair
alex zane alexander
was one of the best corners in football
last year as a rookie you know you talk
about savage and adrian amos and the
secondary i'm with you mike i think the
packers defense you know has the chance
to be a top five certainly a top 10
defense in the nfl
and packers safety josh jones according
to rob demosky of espn.com he sees the
handwriting on the wall and he senses
that his time in green bay is not going
to be
extended so he is staying away from otas
working out in florida because he's
hoping to be traded he was a second
round pick in 2017 and he's ready to
move on and for good reason they've made
him irrelevant they've replaced him and
he's going to be stuck on the bench
until they do trade him or cut him yeah
you're i mean yes he's not gonna start
over their first round pick darnell
savage who you know was one of my man
crushes of the draft i mean not just one
rocket up his butt there was two of them
there and then adrian amos was a hell of
a signing from the chicago bears but
josh jones come on man i mean just you
know be be a good team guy he's got
talent this kid josh jones mike and we
know three safeties on the field in the
nfl is kind of commonplace this day and
age so just because you might not start
doesn't mean you won't get a chance to
get out there and play i don't think
green bay is going to trade them
but but you know i i like the idea of
him forcing the issue and trying to
bring it to a head rather than
languishing and having no options if
they decide in late august to move on
from better get a chance to get ensconce
somewhere else now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports